when the taliban seized power in august
afghanistan's girls soccer team spent
weeks on the run fearing for their lives
finally thanks to an international
rescue effort they managed to flee the
country now they found a new home in
portugal where they received a surprise
visit from one of their heroes
it may not have the mountains the aroma
or the warm embrace of home yet but
lisbon will do as the new home of the
afghanistan youth women's national team
portugal has granted asylum to the 26
players who fled their country in fear
with about 50 family members i feel i
was actually
free
i feel i am free
at a pre-arranged gathering these girls
destined to be role models were
surprised by their own role model
farcundo mutage the captain of the
afghanistan women's team who plays
professionally in canada she'd spent
weeks communicating with the girls and
working to help arrange their rescue
through pakistan then to portugal
they have dedicated so much they have
been so resilient and to finally see
them in person was emotional because
i knew how much they went through and
you know i'm so proud of them they are
so deserving of this and they're just
going to have a fantastic future here
back in afghanistan where the young
women used to play in a stadium with
fans waving the flag of afghanistan
sports of any kind for girls and women
are now banned
girls do not need sport they will be
exposed and not follow the dress code
and islam does not allow that
in portugal home of ronaldo one of
football's all-time greats the door is
open for these young players to try to
achieve whatever they want on the pitch
and off
and let's speak more about this we are
joined now by khalida popal the former
captain of afghanistan's women's
football team she joins us from
copenhagen thank you so much for for
your time this afternoon um you worked
personally to get these girls a new home
in portugal and we understand it's not
only them
but you've helped others get out as well
tell us a little bit more about that
thank you so much
we have helped the
women's national team the senior women's
team to get first group out in australia
thanks to government of australia our
good
teammates helped
the young girls in portugal to get a
home in a host country in portugal
now we are working with a big group
who are also your team and and also
provincial teams yeah the female teams
that they are
we have got them out of afghanistan now
they are in pakistan and we are trying
our best to find a host country for them
it has been very tough
we are talking about 135 people who are
waiting right now in pakistan which is
like 32 players and their family members
that they were displaced from the
provinces that they lived just because
they were playing football and some of
them their houses were burned down and
some of the family members were taken by
taliban
wow um everything that they have have
been through um just to get out of the
country you made a similar journey
yourself out of afghanistan and and in
our report um we heard from one of the
girls who has just arrived in portugal
saying i feel free
um i'm wondering if you could maybe
react to that you know how do you how do
you feel
being so closely involved
with
helping these individuals get out
it feels so good when when women get out
and feel free um
as one of us one of the founding members
of afghanistan women's national team
first women's national team
i found my freedom through football and
the the foundation of women's football
was based on
standing for our right as a women of
afghanistan but also challenging the
culture that was
taking their
the basic human right from women and now
their their life has been in in great
danger
it's it feels good that they have got
the freedom or a safe space
um for me even um
during the
structured government and during the the
nato soldiers being in afghanistan has
been very was very very tough to live
there because it was so much risk that i
faced i had to flee from my country now
the enemy is in afghanistan and also
it's not only justifying
khalid if you could just um tell us
briefly because i mean we've we're
featuring now these positive stories of
people who have
you know been able to leave the country
um who have the assistance and the means
to do so including with your help
what's your message for um those who
have not been so lucky for for those who
are left there
my message to the women and girls of
afghanistan who are trying the best
standing strong and supporting each
other i know it is very tough i am
i am feeling sorry and sad for my people
for especially women in afghanistan i
want to tell you stay strong
we are trying our best to help you in
any way possible i'll be there to help
in any way i can
just stay strong and don't give up
khalid thank you so much for your time
as we mentioned you're the former
captain of afghanistan's women's
football team and and you've been a
great help in in trying to
get these individuals out and and get
them to safety we appreciate
it thank you